yeah yeah one two three hey today was
yeah yeah it was the best detail shoot
ever it's an honor to be in the cover of
details I know this magazine very well
so it was an honor to take pictures for
it and it was everything I dreamed it
was big it's very fun that's probably
the coolest thing is having been in what
kind of one type of magazine for so long
going to details those a little bit like
graduation so that's that aspect of it
is very exciting and also it's pretty
classy people in the magazine cool setup
this is unlike any issue we have ever
done because this is actually in my
apartment check it out with my popcorn
the floor out my little table here I try
and look my best
always and everybody admired the Stars
just like back in the day when it really
meant a lot to go to red carpets and
premieres and things people really took
extra pride in their clothes you know
Frank Sinatra and those guys they always
were dressed to the nines and I think
that was uh that was very classy I
should be the master of this yeah every
once in a while I'll just get like a
great big hug unexpected
yeah I'm still kind of a small-town boy
but every day is an adventure and every
day I'm doing something new and every
day I'm stepping outside the box so I
consider myself to be growing right now
long as I'm growing I never had
celebrity crushes but I do ride ooh
remember teen magazines I was like whoa
what is this phenomenon teen magazines
and at that time it was just Titanic to
just come out Leonardo DiCaprio
it was weird as much as you like the guy
and you like the movie being a young guy
with these girls fawning all over them
you kind of just innately hated it